we may know what you did before you got
me for a living I was a pimp
you know like Gladys Knight in the pitch
you know put on an IMAX screen with the
sound I think I think the audience is
going to love it I've never seen it in
IMAX I want to see it I imagine it's
even more amazing this was made for IMAX
explosion great soundtrack fantastic
visuals great cast great to Rack time we
couldn't be more excited you see things
that you can never see and then on a
regular screen the sound and screen
itself is it's an immersive experience
and you find yourself deeper into the
movie that you can never truly be in a
regular theater sound it's pictures all
those things the high max sound system
you gonna feel every bone every bullet
every every trail every little home Bart
- he could find see it in IMAX it just
makes it so much more special because
you feel so much closer to all the
things going on in the movie when
filmmakers get a kick out of what
they're seeing and that they've it's
sort of the way they dreamt that the
movie would be seen that's that's why we
do what we do
you